people who wait for a filmmaking career
will never have one without course
naming any names can you think of some
people in your life we're very talented
but I've been waiting and maybe it
frustrates you maybe you see the
opportunity in front of them but they
won't take it for whatever reason
um yeah absolutely mostly colleagues I
won't even say friends but just people
that you run into
but what I've understood I have come to
realize is that particularly those
filmmakers have come out of film school
like you're not going to have a crew of
30 on your first in your next film you
know they come out with these great
thesis films and they want to get their
feature made but in this in this age of
independent filmmaking no one's going to
give you a million dollars to do your
your thesis film and when I don't see
them working or trying to to kind of
start from scratch whether it's a short
film whatever it is that to continue to
continue to do the craft until you get
that I must say it's not possible but
I'm really blown away by filmmakers I
know that have a great thesis film from
film school and are waiting to make
their feature film I'm like why aren't
you doing something now you know I don't
want to shoot something on my phone I
don't want to shoot something with a
with the three-person crew I'm like what
are you waiting for but it's it's not a
it's not something I can tell people
they have to figure that out of their
own but if you've been 10 years now and
I know filmmakers that are 10 years out
of film school still thinking they're
gonna get three million dollars to
produce their first film based off their
thesis what do you think that is is it
that they think that they're at a
different status level they don't need
to do that they want people to they
won't have investors I think it's a
combination of that and also it's a
combination of people in this industry I
think everyone looks at their trajectory
going like this you know and it doesn't
you started with a thesis and you have a
crew of 30 and you have all those
millions of dollars worth of equipment
that the school provides for you you get
out do you really want to shoot your
your short film on your iPhone the ones
that work do
you know but the ones that because
that's that's ego you know and in my
experience having done as much as I've
done what I've found is there's certain
film schools and I've hired film school
students you know and but the one I will
say I won't say the ones where they have
the least discipline but the ones with
the most discipline have come from the
Los Angeles Film School they have come
with a discipline to work and it didn't
matter how good their thesis film was if
my crew was small or whatever they
wanted to work they wanted to learn and
they wanted to produce I know there's a
lot of backlash on Millennials that oh
they don't want to work and things like
that I haven't always seen that I've
seen it it can be across many different
you know generation acts I've seen
different work ethics do you think
there's is it generational or is it a
mindset that it's definitely a mindset I
don't find it generational at all if
this is what you want to do you're gonna
do it and you're gonna do it as long as
often as you possibly can the thing I
say to people who want to be writers you
gotta be writing every day if you want
to be a director or filmmaker you should
be trying to make something or shoot
something every month every week if you
can but at least every month you know
it's a craft it's like building a deck
you're right your first step you build
is not gonna maybe be as fancy or as
good but the more you do it the better
you get at it and filmmaking is no
different so I don't really subscribe to
that philosophy as well I'm waiting for
this I'm waiting for the right money I'm
writing I'm waiting for the right people
and right no I'm gonna subscriber that
you have to just kind of go forward if
that's all you're banking on though is
that all you have is your one script
that you want to make perfect you're
gonna have a difficult time do you think
the DIY mindset because there's certain
people that are just like really self
generate like they just they do rely on
themselves they don't expect any handout
and they just want to do something
themselves whereas there's others that
maybe they've had more coddling or
whatever it is you think that there's a
clash do you think they clash sometimes
those two mindsets only on a panel
[Laughter]
yeah because to me it just comes down to
the work can you produce you know so
that it it can - that's it I think
we there certain filmmakers we follow
and we see their career we try to model
I think filmmakers trying to model their
careers after other filmmakers that's
not something I've ever done I've never
looked at someone and said this is how
I'm gonna do it like they did you know
or I'm gonna do this and this is what's
gonna happen my thing has always just
been how do I get my stuff made right
now you know and if I wrote a ten
million dollar script I would have it
but that wouldn't be the first thing I
would try to get made I would have a
fifty thousand dollar script I would
have a ten thousand dollar script I'd
have different things what do I have
what can I do right now
you know and then if that does take what
do I have back here that's ready to go
you